but we have another interesting story
semi-related this is from washington
examiner urban liberals rethink guns and
policing amidst crime spike on their
doorstep there were a couple other
stories i was reading earlier gun sales
are were at a record for uh i believe
this past month it's the second highest
year following last year so we got this
they say abc news ipsos poll published
during the week found that 36 percent of
voters approve of biden's handling of
crime while 61 disapprove on gun
violence 66 percent of voters disapprove
of biden's performance with 32 percent
approving we've seen a poll from gallup
that support for gun control is at its
lowest it's been since 2014. so it was
lower before 2014 a little bit and then
it was higher before that but people are
now all of a sudden coming around and
being like i want to buy guns
there was an article from slate about a
liberal woman and she explained that she
thought guns were dangerous you can't
have them and then her husband was like
i think you need to learn more and go
take a class and then she did and then
she realized hey all of these arguments
for gun control don't make any sense
yeah and uh you know the number of
people getting involved with firearms
and learning about guns has piqued an
all-time high in the beginning of covid
i still remember there was a need for
classes and there was no classes
available for people to even be you know
taught basic gun safety or even how to
handle their firearms to the point where
i was like okay i'm going to create my
own classes i i ran my own classes in
new hampshire literally working with a
special forces green beret teaching
people proper uh proper ways to handle a
firearm proper ways to use a firearm
because if you have something like that
you have a tool that you need to know
how to use it's like you know i think
it's akin to a fire extinguisher and
that's how many people are seeing it
like if you have a fire extinguisher uh
you know
why do you need one if you have the fire
department well obviously the fire
department takes a while to get to your
house so so this doesn't surprise me
especially with the with the levels of
criminality that has been increasing all
throughout the united states obviously
people are going to want to arm
themselves defend themselves and have
something that is akin to a fire
extinguisher during a fire because
there's a lot of fires going around to
say the least yeah because we all know
that uh
the liberals with a little bit of money
that they always have firearms anyway
even if they're saying uh with ban guns
ban guns they got their security they
got this guy with three guns over there
they're all taken care of they got guns
in their house well i'll get rid of guns
get rid of guns all you poor people get
rid of guns
communities yeah yeah you guys
you know
i don't know if you saw this there was a
tweet during the riots last year where
this dude who lived in beverly hills was
like yeah you know the riots amazing
burn the city down and then he tweets
like an hour later why are you coming
towards my house go the other way go the
other way
like they cheer for until they have to
deal with it nancy pelosi wanted machine
gun turrets uh on on the on the capitol
i mean who served yeah
50 pm yeah
these people are insane they cheer on
the military industrial complex they're
surrounded as as you said with people
with firearms with guns security guards
always protecting them but for you as an
individual you shouldn't have the right
to protect yourself get out of here like
you're crazy if you think that you're
gonna take away a right that allows me
to be equal to another man because a lot
of people in these cities are also
realizing you could get a gun
no matter what the laws are criminals
are always going to have a way to get
guns especially in america so so if the
criminals could have guns why can't uh
legally uh you know
law-abiding citizens have guns as well
only rich people should have guns and
and well-connected politicians well
that's like in like in maryland and new
jersey we laugh about that but there's
policies on the books especially with
the machine gun rules that only allow
rich people to have certain uh firearms
where poor people are exempt from having
it because of the restrictions and taxes
that the government has put on them that
makes it almost impossible for people to
have uh machine guns oh bro the cost of
machine guns what are they what what you
maybe you can get one for like 15 000 or
30. if you're very lucky and that
thing's probably falling apart and and
not in good condition
uh
i mean there are tens of thousands of
dollars and then people were able to buy
them before without any kind of major
issues or problems the most amount of
machine gun ownership is per capita in
new hampshire uh that's another reason
why i really like new hampshire and
you know
when we see these like rules and
restrictions especially in new york city
especially in los angeles especially in
places like chicago where people can't
own firearms we're seeing a lot of
homicides because of firearms why is
that and also when there was the whole
thing when they were bringing rape
culture into you know uh uh making a big
deal you know rape culture rape culture
and then they were meeting with guns
take the guns take the guns and it's
like don't you think that woman walking
alone at night should have the little 22
in her
exact so you come out she's gonna shoot
you in your balls shooting your face you
know can we say balls on your pocket
yeah yeah
yeah i try i'm trying to keep it pg
pg-13 i mean you said shoot someone in
the face
no but if a rapist is gonna rape
yourself you know i i don't think that
youtube ain't gonna ban you for talking
about shooting a rapist in the facebook
merging self-destruct no i think you're
okay yeah i mean we're talking about
self-defense yeah
exactly but i gotta be honest i i would
hope that
you know people would would aim for
center mass and not the face because you
might miss and you got to know what's
behind the target or run don't wear high
heels at night just i'll put it this way
i'll put it this way don't take advice
from any of us on what you should do in
the situations you talk to self-defense
experts like luke have been talking to
it's easy for us to be like oh you
should take your gun and now and like
a woman in the situation is going to
have particular self-defense technique
she's going to use i think a gun is one
of those tools especially but it
shouldn't be illegal for her if that's
what she feels safe with she shouldn't
not be allowed to carry it that's what
i'm saying they shouldn't tell her no
you can't carry they do a little weapon
in your purse in case in chicago
it's almost impossible for a regular
person to have a gun but all the
politicians got them they got they got
guns themselves and they got bodyguards
that's how that's how it works yep and
it's absolutely insane i mean if if you
do have a firearm especially at like a
lot of these people in these cities do
you need to get training uh you need to
take this very seriously it's all about
your personal responsibility
it's a lot more
obviously important for you to
understand how to use a firearm than a
fire extinguisher but i think the
analogy is still there and i think it's
still very important it's a tool just
like anything else and if we truly want
to ban things that harm people we should
be banning cheeseburgers and cars but
that's also unrealistic and totally
illogical and totally doesn't make sense
but but that's the logic that they use
to disarm so many americans that live in
these hell holes that don't allow them
to have self-defense which is crazy i
think people should be allowed to have
nuclear weapons
yeah i was thinking later on do you
think people should be allowed to have
flying cars that can drop nuclear
gravity bombs everyone yeah i don't know
anything about well
flying cars is different
why do you think people's cars are gonna
start flying second amendment says the
right of the people to keep and bear
arms so not be infringed nuclear arms or
arms yeah yeah so i mean if you want to
change constitution by all means yeah
maybe we should if a nuclear weapon is
somebody going to buy a nuclear weapon
but yeah you know they would have
written that way
no no back in the day
they uh the founding fathers understood
the concept of privateers and corsairs
regular private individuals who had
warships with some of the most advanced
weaponry on the planet
like a nuclear weapon no they couldn't
they couldn't
they couldn't wipe out a city in half a
second though no i don't think no but
they could in a few hours they bombard a
city on on a port until they come and
blow up the ship like they can try and
sustain bro you can justify it any way
you want what the government should have
we don't even have to go that far i mean
but but we have to acknowledge that one
thing that makes america special is the
right to defend yourself is the second
amendment you don't see that right
translated in other places around the
world and right now we have to take a
victory because we're in a situation
where taking away that right is at one
of the least unpopular moments that it
ever has been in american history that's
amazing that's great we're also seeing a
lot of states
domestically pass a lot of laws that
allow people to open carry conceal carry
and have the ability to defend
themselves because at the end of the day
this is the right to be able to defend
yourself that's it all right let me put
this away
i personally don't think people should
have nuclear weapons nor should
governments however the constitution is
is it's it's written as it is and so
that means it needs to be amended
because no one should have the authority
to just decide at this point we are
going to take away you know your
constitutional protections you can't do
that unilaterally it's got to be it's
got to be
voted there's certain guns that they're
not allowed to have and that's and stuff
like that oh so you just didn't give
them everything you could have machine
guns you just have to pay a lot of money
what about rpgs i think people should
have a right to keep and bear rpgs yeah
rocket propelled grenade that's right
i'm reminded of biden saying that you're
going to need
f-15s and
and nukes in order to fight the us
government and then a couple days later
he had to
withdraw from afghanistan after a
massive military loss in that country uh
just embarrassing the united states
causing
crazy human harm throughout his uh you
know leaving of afghanistan which was
absolutely done in a foolish way the the
issue i see with the erosion of the
second amendment
one day some politicians came up and
said well certainly they couldn't have
mend this weapon and now we're at the
point where democrats have literally
literally advocated banning all
semi-automatic weapons that would be
like your standard glock 17. they want
to ban that but the cops can have it and
at that point you're literally taking
away the right keeping bear arms if you
let them erode it they will keep doing
it so we we come to this point where
they it's not just democrats it's both
it's all parties democrats republicans
are like it's the establishment the unit
party they have tried to to just strip
apart as many amendments in the
constitution as possible interpreting
them the way they that gives them and
guarantees them power thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you